nobody's perfect nobody's wise but to
feel the kind of
pain in a way of lacking wisdom and to
crave it
and to realize it's the most important
thing in life and to dedicate your life
to this kind of endless journey is
really what life is actually all about
you're a cognitive behavioral therapy
trained
psychologist why are you writing about
marcus aurelius
that's a really good question because
actually my first love was
philosophy and i i think i came to
philosophy
looking for a philosophy of life really
you know something that would help me uh
feel better about life
cope with adversity and i didn't find it
at university when i was doing a
philosophy degree
and so then i started training in
psychotherapy and stuff like that
then after that i realized i'd missed
something
which is the one school one major school
of ancient philosophy that you don't
normally study
in an undergraduate philosophy
curriculum uh so it's like the
stone that the builders rejected became
the cornerstone kind of thing
and so discover stories as well i
thought this is the thing that i was
looking for the whole time i was at
university nobody ever told me about
and uh so i'll get into stoicism and i
realized it was also
the philosophical inspiration for
cognitive therapy not a lot of people
know that
so the two things wedded together and i
thought oh cognitive therapists must all
be really into stoicism then
and turned out they weren't so i ended
up writing a book about that
and i thought oh this is a nerdy obscure
subject that no one's ever going to be
interested then i'm never going to be
talking about this on
podcasts or anything like that in the
future and then it's
weirdly it became trendy my a few years
after i started writing about it
and i got dragged into this thing that
suddenly people were getting tattooed on
them
and stuff like that it kind of became a
bit uh hit
just as i was getting a little bit old
actually i feel like you know
i'm getting older now young kids that
are into it and stuff
uh it's i'm reliably told by the
publishing industry that it's
millennials that work in the tech
industry
that are the the demographic that are
interesting
well see the thing is you know i always
think i'm in a very lucky position
because i talk to so many people
so sometimes when i'm answering
questions about stores is my thing
that's easy because i've asked them
and they keep telling me why it is so
i'll tell you what they've told me
basically so they tell me that they feel
overwhelmed
by social media and the news media
bombarding them
with alarmist stuff about things that
aren't under the direct control
like they think the media are trying to
fear manga and instill hated
by which is accurate probably
and they don't know how to deal with
that and they feel that there is some
kind of philosophy of life to cope with
it
um but like nietzsche said you know god
is dead
um but we're still kind of living in his
shadows so they want something that's
kind of like
what christianity used to do for our
grandparents and so on
um but a lot of people today especially
i think the tech industry
are are quite rationalist and they
they want a secular philosophy that's
based on reason
rather than faith revelation or
tradition
and so they find in stoicism and there
are historical reasons for this
uh why they would uh a secular
alternative to christianity and a kind
of secular
they want something like cbt that is
bigger that's a whole like a western
yoga they also say
i'm just telling you all the stuff they
tell me man of you
so like uh yeah they tell me we want our
western yoga it's like buddhism
but western and so they want more than
cbt they want a whole way of life
and so that's what stoicism gives them
yeah i've been fascinated thinking about
what we're missing with no no consistent
religion anymore now
and the most recent riots at the capitol
i think a part of that this anno me this
normlessness that we've got at the
moment
tradition is out of the window where
this science is the new god materialist
reductionist
standpoints on everything of the other
victor
yeah i just wrote an article about that
yesterday you're right on the button
there buddy with the topical
aspect of this for sure because that's
exactly what people are asking about and
it seems odd that people would say
well does this ancient greek philosophy
that might be really relevant to the
riots and capital l
so you know i mean i feel people hearing
that might think that sounds really
implausible
but you know already loads of people are
saying
yes anime like you're saying it's
disillusionment
you know people have no sense of
direction they've lost touch with our
values
and the more people are confused about
their moral values often the more kind
of rigid and dogmatic
like you know than draconian they become
uh and trying to force their
non-existent values on other people
absolutely paradoxically and the more
reflective people are about their values
you know and in touch with them the more
flexible
they tend to be about them strangely um
so i think really i paradoxically
there's a connection between the lack of
deep
sincere moral self-examination in modern
society
and this kind of rigid dogmatic
prejudice and also
there's a sight there's a really obvious
psychological angle to this
and it's kind of it's just i don't know
like it's so strange because it's
glaringly obvious
and nobody ever does anything really to
address it on a societal level
and that is we know that anger bias is
judgment
and anger is related to political
prejudice and racial prejudice
and religious power that's been known
for decades
and yet we allow the media to go crazy
by provoking anger and fear
uh and social media like partly because
it's very structured kind of feeling
that
escalating things like crazy and so it's
no
surprise that prejudices like
begin to proliferate in society we need
to help people manage their anger
and we need to help them reflect on
their values and weirdly those are
two things that stoicism is
fundamentally interested in
marcus aurelius had big problems with
anger didn't he i think based on what i
know about him that was probably the
biggest vice emotion that he had
he he says that i mean we've got slender
evidence really but he says
uh in the meditations that he was
worried he was going to lose his temper
a few times and do something that he'd
regret
and he's very preoccupied with anger but
so are our stoics
i i think he had problems managing his
own anger though
and on the other hand the histories so
we have these two sides of marx aurelius
we have what he writes himself in his
private journal
so kind of the the inner psychological
story and
i i by the way there's internal evidence
that's fairly convincing to most
scholars that this was never intended
for publication
i agree with that i think it seems
unlikely that this was meant
for publication whereas seneca's letters
are
or definitely literary devices and they
were clearly meant for publication
um but in private marcus talks about his
anger in public
the histories of his reign um seem to
say the opposite that he was very calm
he wasn't easily provoked there was one
time when he lost his temper
and ordered the beheading of a germanic
chieftain
but then he walked it back and sent the
guy into exile
what after he had his head chopped off
no not after he had
sorry mate we'll just stitch that back
on we can stitch it back oh and don't
worry
don't worry we'll fix that by a bit of
glue or something
yeah you know you'll be right here no no
i i think he'd give the order and then
walks it back he sent the guy into exile
instead
who was it i was i was reading this
morning doing my research
was it augustus that
stabbed a slave in the eye with a spear
and then apologized afterwards and was
like what do you want
and the guy said i just want my eye back
i love that story you're very close it
was hadrian and it was actually a
stylist it's a thing that like a
fountain pen
basically you know like these are such a
childish thing to do
i know like it's like a kid having a
like a lot of
people that lose a temper in history
they do seem like toddlers
like having a hadrian people love
hadrian i'm writing about hadrian at the
moment and i really see him as a giant
toddler
like he's incredibly vain and
bad tempered and paranoid and you know
like but yeah he stabbed this guy in the
eye and he said okay
is there anything i can do to make it up
for you and the guy said oh i want is my
eye back
that's a great story because it shows
and the capital hill rights are funnily
enough an example of that
sometimes when people do things in anger
they cause harm that can easily be
repaired
or maybe completely irreparable that's
one of the things that we should try and
do a lot
surely to take that third-party
perspective
and make the action that we would have
wanted us to do
in the freshness of mind that we'll have
tomorrow morning
not in the heat of the moment right now
that would be a great idea
like you should uh you should spread the
word about that i think
you know i think that i think if
everyone did that you know the world
would be a much rosier place wouldn't it
but people are acting impulse
actually it's very interesting that
that's generally true
that the most of those people who write
and stuff if you got them in a camera
moment
they would probably say oh i would never
do that but
you know when people do crazy things
they often surprise themselves
because your brain goes into a different
mode of functioning actually
and all these biases kick in and you're
no longer reasoning
clearly like you start under me we know
that people underestimate risk
when they're angry they jump to
premature conclusions they make sweeping
generalizations and stuff like that
like so your brain's in a different mode
of functioning and your thinking is
foggy so yeah you're right
the stoics have this strategy that's
like a time-out strategy we'd call it in
therapy
which is knowing that you're in this
crazy state
in the fog of war wouldn't it make sense
once you've spotted that
to go yeah hang on a minute maybe i
should maybe wait until i've calmed down
a bit
and then i'll decide you know like
whether i want to kick in the door
to the uh the capital building or you
know
like pick up speaking speaker pelosi's
lectern
and carry it down there really a good
thing did you see
donald did you see this so i saw this
unbelievable photo
where they'd stormed the capitol
building and they were going through the
entrance way
but they'd stayed inside of the ropes
the walkway
wow i didn't see that like i saw a video
where the cops i don't know what was
going on actually
as you know i'm not even gonna say it
but some of this whatever went on there
it was really quite shocking
and uh at the same time though you know
i should say the stoix advisors
to say not to be shocked by things but
to say you know
to remind ourselves in a sense we should
have seen this coming
uh you know well it happened it happened
it can't be unbelievable because it
happened
yeah i know actually people were
predicting it you know one of my friends
wrote an article last november
like the you know talked about exactly
this sort of thing happening
and uh so it's like people have been
telling us for ages
it's like in cassandra in greek
mythology she was given the power of
prophecy
but cursed so that nobody would believe
her and so i feel there's a lot of
cassandra's walking about at the moment
people like i told you this was going to
happen
if nobody listened right so the stoics
say what
you know it's all too common that people
go this is unbelievable but what we
should say
is there were so there are always signs
and we should be asking ourselves why we
didn't pay more attention to the signs
earlier that would be a more rational
philosophical way of processing this do
we have anything left to learn
from marcus aurelius because there's
only a limited amount of information
that we've got
to go on him is there a day where all of
the insights will be exhausted haven't
we already reached that
man this is a question close to my heart
because i'm in the middle of writing not
one but two books about him at the
moment
but which is something i'm told doesn't
normally happen in publishing
but i'm doing a graphic novel at the
moment about his life
and then i'm also writing a biography
and i thought
there are like at least half a dozen
biographies of marcus aurelius is
and my last book has a lot of
biographical stuff so i thought i wanted
to write another biography of it marx it
really is
and the strange thing is yeah well i
immediately i thought there's loads of
things that i still think are worth
saying about him
like there are people the things that
people ask me all the time that aren't
and how to think like a roman emperor
and i wish i'd had space to address them
and so
and in terms of his life story you know
i keep coming across
new angles and thinking you know why is
no
why is nobody ever written about this
before
i'll give you a sneak peek right uh
hadrian
had um the guy that advises us by the
way
there's a polish guy that advises us on
the historical authenticity
of the the stuff that we're writing
about for the graphic novel
and uh he's a big fan of the frumentari
who were the secret police in the roman
empire
strangely like that's his kind of like
niche the
area and hadrian was really into the
secret police
and the de la torres who are informals
he had spies everywhere because he was
super paranoid
and i think no one's ever really written
about the fact that marcus
really is probably new that he was
growing up
in villas that were full of potential
informers
and that everybody kind of knew
epictetus writes about this
epictetus his writings marcus aurelius
was acquainted with says
everybody knows this if you slag off
caesar it will get back to him
and you know you could be for the chop
like so you have to watch what you say
when kisses they had so many servants
and slaves in those houses
that any of them would potentially go
and grass you up and then they'd get
you know paid a lot of gold for for
doing it
so they really felt they were being
watched all the time
and the historia augusta said something
quite creepy about that it says marcus i
really us
was reared under the gaze of hadrian
well
so then if you read the meditations
marcus says in it things like
never do anything that requires walls or
curtains
now that suddenly takes on a different
meaning when you realize that
he grew up in this environment
surrounded by
informals and spies in the service of
this crazy paranoid
emperor who kept executing potential
rivals to the throne
so nobody's writing about that though as
far as i'm aware now i think it
sheds a light a connection between the
historical events and and the
significance of some of the things that
that marcus is talking about yeah
because you can only see it in that
broader context right
i was um i spent my birthday last year
on the stowa uh in athens uh which was
like being in the bar
were you in the you mean in the bar
beside that or no
on the stacks of the painted porch yeah
no either
no you mean the store atelier the the
one that's like a museum in the agora
but yeah it's all shiny and new
yeah well is that not on the spot of
where the other
oh is it not are you gonna ruin this for
me donald that was my birthday
actually i went that back you were
really close though you were just across
the street from it
like that's uh that's a that's actually
a kind of a museum it's the yeah yeah
the store of atlas
okay and so it's a replica right but
it's beautiful
and uh across the road there's this
dirty hole on the ground full of garbage
and graffiti and stuff with some like
rubble in it
and a lot of cats and that's the store
boycott
which ironically used to be this the
original store poke you know it means
painted porch like because it was like
an art gallery it had these four
huge paintings by the leading artists of
the day so the stories lectured in front
of these works of art
it would have been as beautiful maybe as
the the store that you were on there's
still a
there's are totally yeah you were on the
wrong couch buddy
google maps needs it's had two and a
half thousand years to get the
directions right and obviously google
maps has taken me to the wrong place
no i loved it i spent last the birthday
before at the vatican
and around the roman forum and then the
agora and the parthenon and
everything else this year i thought just
a wonderful wonderful way
to uh that's amazing i love doing things
like that i feel like i'm very lucky
i like to meet other people that have
had a chance to travel more people
should do it because it's not
really primitively expensive when the
pandemic's over obviously it's going to
be easier
but i'm in athens at the moment so like
i'm just you know down the road from
where you were
if it's any consolation right the store
the place you were basically in the
agora right so you were standing
on those steps looking across the place
where socrates used to teach
and also the prison my good friend where
he was executed
ah that is cool i'll tell you something
even cooler about that
right so one of the things that i think
is nerdily cool
is most of what we know well a lot of
what we know about roman history comes
from books
and some of them are unreliable like
they're politically biased a lot
just even we have evidence in satires
we're not sure if they're joking or not
right
but what's really weird is sometimes
archaeologists will dig something up
and think oh my like no way this kind of
confirms
something that previously we only knew
in writing right
and they were digging in the
agora and they for the prisoners and
they found something actually really
kind of weird
they found a little statuette of
socrates in the prison building
now they may have used us for other
things but typically that would be like
in a little shrine or something
like you're honoring a deceased ancestor
or something
so they say it kind of looks like the
athenians fell
and they didn't think he's like kind of
known for this right like they felt bad
about having executed him
and then they thought we'll put a little
shrine up like because you know like
we've actually quite liked him like try
and walk it back try and walk the
execution back
so like you said earlier with the
beheading they were like
well we'll try and fix this by putting a
lot of statue of them in there
yeah we love you really socrates sorry
socrates aurelius was the emperor of
rome but he was following a greek born
philosophy
because the romans weren't that good at
philosophy
like they um they they had this thing
about loving greek they really admired
greek culture when they conquered greece
um they decided that they felt bad about
that i get like a lot of ancient
histories about people
regret yeah they totally trashed
athens and greece and destroyed the
libraries and things and gutted it it
was sacked by a roman dictator
called sulla and then the subsequent
generation exactly like we're saying
felt had a big guilt trip about it and
they
they thought we actually quite like
greek culture and some people say also
they stole all the books and kind of
distributed them and sold them
and so people kind of found out a lot
about uh
about greece because because they
pillaged it basically
and uh and then they started to embrace
greek culture
and get more and more into it and the
weird thing was they they really took to
stoicism
um because stoix they thought were a bit
more tough-minded and that kind of
resonated with roman values they thought
themselves
they liked greeks but they thought of
greeks as kind of lightweights
and like a bit effete
a bit fancy and they thought we want to
like you guys
but if you're a bit tougher like us and
so they were like oh the stoics
there you go like the stoics are the the
tougher side of greek culture
so the romans completely embraced
stoicism and actually the guy you
mentioned earlier augustus
was the founder of the roman empire and
the first
emperor and we don't know much about
this but cryptically
we know that he had two stoic tutors and
he wrote a book on philosophy which is
lost now
it's actually an exaltation to
philosophy which is normally like a
speech
like a motivational speech trying to
encourage usually aimed at young men
trying to inspire them to get into
philosophy
and uh so it seems that he kind of
dabbled in stoicism and maybe set a
precedent then for later emperors to
kind of associate with it
by the time you get to marcus aurelius
you've got the first example of somebody
who seems
like uh what's the expression you know
like uh
they're just a full-on card carrying
stoic uh
as emperor but also being into greek
culture was trendy at that time
upon reflecting and all of the different
stories about how
zeno of citium was he crashed in his
ship and then he
found himself in a bookstore and all of
the different stories
that i seem to hear to do with the the
way that people began their
philosophical journey in
in and around that period it's so
romanticized yes there will probably
have been a little bit of artistic
license
used but hearing the way that marcus
aurelius spoke about himself the leader
of what was essentially the free world
well it wasn't that free
but the leader of the world at the time
um hearing the way that he spoke hearing
even stories about augustus you know he
was into philosophy trying to write
these
these speeches and treaties to bring
young men into philosophy
what's happened between then and any
point after then in history
including now where you have these
philosopher kings yeah i just wonder why
it was obviously seen as a competitive
advantage to be able to
understand the inner workings of the
human mind and what does meaning mean
and what is purpose in life etc
why did that stop are you asking me
where did it all go wrong
yes yeah basically um
well okay this is going to be a
controversial one and actually
historians are about unsure about the
answer to that
but the traditional answer that people
tend to give is
the christianity supplanted
for greek philosophy and you know
this is debated by some people but you
know conventionally people will say well
the christians closed the greek
philosophical schools and
banned teaching a philosophy and and
christianity became
dominant and it was uh
in some ways antagonistic to a lot of
the learning
that had accumulated up until that point
now on the other hand
uh christianity to me in any way
looks really super stoic like
christianity
there are many um kind of passing
allusions to stoicism in the new
testament
and several of church fathers we know
studied stoicism before they became
christians
saint augustine tartullion some of the
gnostics were into stoicism
and that you know early christians in
general they saw the stoics as being
like the closest thing
in pagan philosophy to christianity i'll
give you a good example of that you know
dante's
um divine comedy in the second book of
it and the purgatory
um the person who's guarding the gates
of purgatory
is a famous stoic called cato the
younger or cato of utica
and so dante's basically saying like if
it wasn't for the fact that you don't
believe in jesus
like buddy you would be like basically a
saint
well you're like that you're basically a
pagan saying like you're the closer
you're as close to the gates of heaven
as you can
you can basically get and that was how
he sort of portrayed cato
um this kind of like uh you know as
as a stoic who was kind of as close as
pagan culture got
to christianity and people have said
many christians have said that but
marcus are really yes they read the
meditations and thought
this sounds kind of christian in places
there's a banner where he even says you
should love your enemies and things like
that
why i mean that sounds like the new
testament also a bit trivia for you
um the stoics are actually mentioned in
the new testament
not a lot of people know that in the
acts of the apostles
uh saint paul goes to the ariel pagas
which is
just near where you where you went to
the acropolis right like
there's a big rock covered in broken
beer bottles and graffiti
anarchy symbols at the bottom of the
acropolis
called the ariel pagas the the like the
the rock of mars
where they used to give um speeches and
things and saint paul goes there and
gave a famous sermon
to a bunch of epicurean and stoic
philosophers and he quotes a
stoic poet to them called paritis
so that the students were kind of
connected to christianity and they
influenced
christianity especially this idea of
brotherly love that you get in
christianity
the main precedent for that in uh
hellenistic culture is in
in stoic philosophy people hearing
christians say that would be like that
sounds like stoicism
and i think if you read marxist religion
you can see he talks a lot about
you know brotherly love and natural
affection and cosmopolitanism and
yada yada that's why people read it and
think there's something christian about
this
hmm i'm currently halfway through the
immortality key bry brian murarescu do
you
have you read this i haven't read that
song actually what's it like
he has it's part of the um
psychoactive pagan uh
conversion theory i can't remember the
full the full theory of it i need to get
it before but it's all about is it
leucis yeah lucius
yeah and the cookrion um which was this
uh the priestesses at the time used to
give these particular drinks and have
these
rituals and his argument is that it was
a psychoactive substance
yeah yeah the ergot that was in the
grain um and it's an entire book
it's he it's like 400. yeah yeah yeah
the immortality key brian
you should get the idea yeah i should
check that out very very well done um
right enough enough learning about the
the actual history
what did the stoics say about finding
purpose in life people need that that i
know me at the moment what do they say
about finding person
it's a good thing and we should all do
that but the the the stoics are
like the the great grandchildren of
socrates right i see them as all being
part of the same
socratic stoic tradition essentially um
there's one author
that ancient author says the stoics are
a socratic sect so this aspect really
lines up with socrates right so socrates
said the unexamined life is not worth
living
which is pretty hardcore but he said you
know life is all about
finding your values he calls it the the
uh
find questioning the most important
things in life he calls us
we would say your values or they also
call it the
artie the virtues um
so socrates uh spent his whole life
interrogating people
about what's the meaning of justice
what's the meaning of courage you know
what's the nature of the good what's the
nature of virtue
and he said you know he wanted to do
that in the afterlife at his trial
and he said if they told him they would
release him and send him into exile
but he would maybe be executed or tried
in another city if he didn't keep his
gob shot
and he kept on asking questions about
these things he he said you i wouldn't
be able to stop like there's no point
doing
sending me into exile it goes because
i'm just going to carry on doing it
like that's what he says in court and
plato's apology which is
totally unapologetic ironically
so yeah like he not only does he say
it's a good thing he says it's actually
the meaning of life
is to question your values and explore
them really deeply
and you know that's why
socrates thought that wisdom was
virtually unattainable
and so he insisted on calling himself
not a sophisticated not a wise man
like the other gurus around did but he
called himself philosophers
like a lover of wisdom or a friend of
wisdom and the connotation of that plato
makes really clear
is it socrates said i don't have wisdom
but i have the next best thing
which is a love respect and admiration
of wisdom
like so somebody who genuinely from the
bottom of their heart aspires to wisdom
is almost as good as somebody who
actually is wise
like you know they're almost as
admirable they're a seeker
after truth and they're on the right
path like the hearts in the right place
kind of thing and socrates wants to say
like that that's the meaning of life
right nobody's perfect nobody's wise but
to
feel the kind of pain in a way of
lacking wisdom
by and to crave it like and to realize
it's the most important thing in life
and to dedicate your life to this kind
of endless journey
like is really what life is actually all
about you know it's more about the
journey than the destination in a sense
for socrates it's about the method of
socratic questioning
and so we like you we were saying
earlier we live in a very unquestioning
society now i want to emphasize that
because
if you go on the internet you'll find
it's full of self-help books and
articles
but i think there's something deeply
ironic about this because
although everywhere we go we're
surrounded by self-help advice
i still feel there's a massive lack
of reflection in modern society
and sometimes i think people are using
self-help actually
as an avoidance strategy like a way of
that
i'm very attuned to this from being a
cognitive therapist
because any decent modern cognitive
therapist probably any
modern psychotherapist should tell you
the first thing a psychotherapist
normally ends up doing
especially these days i think more over
time in their initial assessment session
is asking clients what existing
self-help or therapy strategies they use
and often getting them to stop doing a
lot of them like because
many of the strategies people use are
actually counterproductive we now
realize
and you know there's a lot of bad
self-help and psychological advice that
circulates on
on the internet so although people talk
about self-help and they're kind of
fascinated by it in our society it's
like a huge thing
like uh i'll go and i'll give you a
really clear example of that
it's my favorite subject right now super
topical anger
right hardly anybody is really bothered
to talk about and do anything about
anger in themselves and in society
the people that talk about self-help are
more likely to be talking about
personal suffering like anxiety and
depression
but they'll seldom really addressing
feelings of anger
there are psychological reasons for that
and we know that to be the case
i think anger is the royal road to
self-improvement though
i think people are really missing a
trick there i think it's much easier
in some ways to address anger first like
and there's a huge
potential there for self-improvement if
we could just kind of as a society
encourage people to question their anger
more and the stoics thought anger was
the main thing we should be working on
precisely because they said you know
it's the the emotion
that's most obviously a threat to
society
uh it's the most interpersonal emotion
in a sense
so i really that's kind of one of my
passions at the moment
and i use that word advisedly is that we
need to get people to kind of really do
self well more on anger
why it's a massive gap that's
interesting
i for better or for worse
anger is an emotion that for me is very
very very rare
i think i'm fairly cognizant at knowing
what's going on the texture of my own
mind is something i'm not totally
ignorant to
um and yet over um the last month or so
there was a period where i got angry and
oh my god
it is such a hell of an emotion
especially when you're not necessarily
attuned to it there's other things that
occur more frequently in my life
and it's like the devil that you know
you you understand okay we're at this
stage we're at that stage and you almost
get into the rhythm of understanding how
you deal with it
but anger is so all-encompassing and
when you then scale that up into crowds
these crowds can be virtual online in a
group in a
a reddit thread on a q anon sub sub
forum or whatever it might be or they
can be in person at a football riot or
the capitol hill
it can cause that um i i wanted to loot
back to something you mentioned as well
about
how people are using personal
development to almost stave off the
different fears that they have
and i'm 100 in agreement i've had this
theory for a long time that the current
longevity biohacking productivity
movements
time management all of these things are
working on an ernest becker's denial of
death
they're people terrified about the fact
that lives don't have any greater
meaning
we've removed our connection to the
wider world to nature to the ore of the
night sky
and what they're doing oh if i live
longer if i get more done in less time
then i won't have this fear anymore i
can give you a long list of reasons why
self-help is an avoiding strategy by
many many reasons here's number one
clients come into therapy
they'll usually go i've got this huge
library of self-help books i've been
reading for years
right so a lot of self-help reading just
encourages what we call ruminative
thinking
so people are thinking about the
problems and chewing them over not
actually doing anything to change them
a lot of self-help strategies involve
emotional control or suppression
like so using breathing techniques
visualization techniques mantras and
things
are ways that people use to actually
avoid engaging with their emotions and
processing them
naturally um people use self-help as a
way of getting direction from authority
figures like psychologists
rather than becoming more self-reliant
to identify their own values
but there are many ways that that people
use
self-help advice in a way that's
obviously
counterproductive and the clients of
therapy will tell you that themselves
like it's very common clients come into
therapy
and they say you know i read all these
articles and i've got this massive
library of self-help books
but i'm not getting any better right and
you know there are reasons for that i
was having a look at
objective representation and cognitive
distancing
uh when reading your book and how does
that relate to the stoic work
and what is it and how can people
utilize it
fantasia catalepticae is the the greek
um
and it it's hard to translate but it
actually means a
an impression or a representation that
grasps reality
as grounded in reality and but the
stories appear to mean by this so
objective representation is pr had those
kind of paraphrase of that
and it it means describing events in a
way that suspends
value judgments or emotive rhetoric
right
i was going to say a minute ago actually
if you want a experience anger like you
were saying you know just go on
the the comments on youtube or something
like that for five minutes and
you know it's like a laboratory
experiment in anger exposure
like it's hard and even if you don't
have anger you've got to deal with other
people's right
but the internet is full of people using
strongly emotive language um
like you know rather than saying people
say things like
you know you shot me down in flames and
tore a strip
off me when they could say oh you just
expressed disagreement with part of what
i said
like so there's still exponents this is
why cicero thought the stoics were
rubbish
at legal rhetoric like he was like you
guys
there was no drama there was no there
was no showmanship with it
yeah he goes you make everything too
concise and too kind of banal
and they were like well like that's to
get rid of the effect of rhetoric right
like you know like sure in a locker
you're trying to manipulate the audience
we're trying to undo that
i call still some kind of anti-rhetoric
or counter rhetoric
and you know in the ancient world there
were these lawyers
stroke self-help gurus called the
sophists
and i used to for a long time think we
don't really have sophists in the
modern world maybe we have like
self-help gurus and stuff but it's not
quite the same
and then one day it dawned on me like we
do
we have digital's office it's like
facebook is basically a massive softest
and so is twitter so that the sophists
would just say whatever would get a
reaction out of people
like and socrates was like this is a
problem man you guys are just saying
whatever
you know evokes anger or what like
gets the clock the crowd to applaud you
or whatever and you don't really
give two hoots about the truth like
you're just saying whatever gets a
response from people and that just leads
to
distortion that amplifies people's
emotions and one day it dawned on me i
thought yeah we don't have sophists
like that anymore because now they've
been taken over by algorithms that's
basically what social media the social
media is it's massive softest
and so we need socrates we need the
stoics to teach us
this how to protect ourselves against
sophistry
and rhetoric and the manipulation of our
emotions through
the use of emotive language so stoics
say we should learn to re-describe
things in a more down-to-earth and
objective way
so that we can stick to the facts by and
not distort things
and and kind of in a way that files our
emotions up
how can people apply that cognitive
distancing obviously it sounds great
how do they do it the stories just want
us to prac like when we feel that we're
getting upset or angry about something
first of all like they want us just to
pause and
maybe to say to ourselves it's not
things that upset us but rather our
opinions about them
so realizing that it's our way of
thinking
that's causing us to to feel so upset
rather than the event itself
take responsibility basically for our
value judgments and then to redescribe
it
to say well what's actually happening
here in most specific down to earth and
objective language
and when we do that the stoics think
that helps us
to mod the the effect of our emotions
and then the other thing
is to broaden our perspective because
i mean the stoics were way ahead of
their time right
and if you think the stoics were ahead
of their time my friend
like you want to go and read some
sigmund freud like because that wasn't
that long ago
and people were people still use freud
today right even though that would be
like alchemy or something like you know
that like freud was pre-scientific
psychology right so i remember when i
started as a psychotherapist
psychoanalytic approaches were still
kind of not that rare you know people
still took them quite seriously
um largely freudianism and its
traditional farmers kind of died
off now but if you compare what he was
doing to what the
uh the stoics were doing they were way
ahead of their time
like this don't seem futuristic compared
to freud
like freud had no idea really what he
was talking about
um and you know most of regard contrary
people are gonna be shocked if i say
this but
i i think there's very little of value
in freud's writings and i have a
master's degree in psychoanalytic theory
incidentally i trained as a
psychoanalytic counselor
um and i had psychoanalysis myself uh
just was it not just projection was it
not just an entire lifetime of internal
projection yeah
freud um i'm very interested in frey's
biography actually freud's father died
and then he had a lot of
dreams about it that were traumatic for
him and he decided to interpret his own
dreams
and he believed that he unconsciously
was attracted sexually to his own mother
um and frightened of his father uh and
there was this kind of love triangle and
then he just assumed that that applied
to everybody else
which is obviously crazy right because
he's hardly seen any clients he'd seen
about
five or six clients i think by the time
he'd already decided that this was true
of everyone
and freud hated therapy like he he
really
didn't like doing it if you look at his
collected writings you know there's
whatever 12 volumes or something
i think there's only one volume actually
about therapy and the rest of it's all
this crazy theory and
him doing psychoanalysis and leonardo da
vinci and
moses and like weird speculative
anthropology and stuff
he just wanted to be a kind of armchair
like
uh you know theorist or whatever really
is that not the the biggest distinction
between what he did
and what the stoics did that it was a
philosophy of action
born in the crucible of real life yeah
and stoicism lasted a lot longer i mean
freudian psychoanalysis was trendy for
like i don't know like sixty years or
seventy years or whatever
and then it's pretty much dead in the
water i know it's
it's like like i see it's like a feud
about like alchemy now or something
um but stoicism flourished in the
ancient world for five centuries
why and that meant you know but to
marcus aurelius socrates was ancient
history
like socrates died 500 years
before uh before marcus aurelius um
was even born and uh you know that
is like like i was talking about
somebody in the late medieval period
right so they're like we've been doing
this for a long time
and so a lot of people in greece and
rome and all over
the known world have been practicing
stoicism we know of 80
uh stoic philosophers from antiquity
the names of authors or teachers but
there were loads of them
um so like it was something that they
developed over a very long period of
time
and i i'm still puzzled by and impressed
by it like how much of it is
is relevant and is confirmed by modern
research and psychology so
what the one i was going to mention is
we know now that when people get angry
or depressed they they there's a
narrowing in the scope of attention
so people can normally pay attention to
like maybe five or six things at once
so you could be driving your car and
listening to the radio and and maybe
thinking about what you're gonna have
for dinner and also kind of like
telling your kids in the back seat to
keep the noise down or whatever right
so you can walk and chew gum like you
can do more than one thing at a time you
can multitask or whatever
except when you're under stress like so
when people
like become very emotionally distressed
the scope of attention narrows
and they're less capable to think about
multiple things at once
right and we do this thing called threat
monitoring where we tend to really zero
and put under a magnifying glass that
the things that we see is
threatening or upsetting and the stoics
realized that we did that
like freud has no concept really that's
equivalent to this
he thinks what you should really be
doing is trying to figure out whether it
symbolizes castration in your dreams or
something like that
like which nobody nobody thinks is
helpful
for the love of god leave it alone freud
literally thought like freud literally
thought
all he says all forms of anxiety are
disguised castration anxiety like all
forms of anxiety
like that's how crazy freud's theory was
anyway
the um the stoics were like no like i
mean anxiety is caused by your value
judgments
like you'd think like most people might
assume right so if you think something's
really really bad and it's about to
happen then you're probably going to
feel anxious right
it's got to do with the value that you
invest in external events that
especially if they're
you know they're not directly under your
control it's going to feel more anxiety
provoking
that's common sense in a way and so the
stoics think
also we narrow our attention down onto
things and they realize if you broaden
the scope of your attention
it'll tend to dilute the emotional
response so you might have said
something that annoys me
on twitter right maybe i don't know
anything about you and i haven't seen
what your day's been like
all i know is that you just said
something that could be taken in a
slightly offensive way
like so now taking that one remark in
isolation
i'm going to focus my attention narrowly
on it and have this kind of intense
emotional reaction to it
whereas if i broadened my attention like
i might you know
if i didn't know more about you i might
think or maybe you do a lot of good
things
you know maybe you've had a bad day like
you know maybe you gave money to charity
yesterday like so there would be a more
rounded
picture of you that's really one of the
things that's lacking in modern society
we react to these little slices of
people's character behavior rather than
viewing their personality in a rounded
way
socrates talks about this problem
explicitly um actually in relation to
his own wife
xanthopy so people say oh my god how can
you stand to live with that woman
because she had a notoriously bad temper
right and socrates was like but she's a
really
good wife and a good much she just
shouts at me occasionally yes
she threw a bucket of water over me once
but like
i try and interpret her behavior on her
round and she's also like a really
awesome person
why so socrates has this whole dialogue
about it
where he says you know you've got to
view
people you've got to go past the
appearance and get to the reality
and that means like focusing in a more
broad way
on somebody's character as a whole and
we don't do that today we narrow our
attention down social media by its very
nature potentially encourages us to do
that
because it speeds up communication by
abstracting little pieces of information
out but that prevents us really from
getting to know people properly
and you know to understand all this to
forgive all the saying goes well
you know i don't know if we could take
that literally but certainly the more we
know about people the less likely we are
to have knee-jerk emotional responses to
the the things that we do especially if
we make an effort
by to maintain that rounded perspective
on things
because on the one hand i can see the
nasty thing that you said
and i have maybe i still have an
emotional reaction to that but when my
attention is broadened i'm also seeing
and remembering other nice things that
you did and so that
compensates or it balances it out so i
can still disapprove of the thing that
you did
but not be completely emotionally
overwhelmed by it because i'm
adopting a more balanced perspective
what would marcus aurelius and the
stoics have to say about
facing adversity they think it's a good
thing
like which seems like a truism but there
were other people that thought it was a
bad thing
like there were other philosophers in
the ancient world that thought you'd be
better off going
and living in a commune and avoiding
quite like
allegedly epicureans will get upset if i
say this because there's some
disagreement about it
but in the ancient world people thought
the stoics and epicureans were almost
polar opposites
and epicurus lived in this little
private garden
on the uh outside uh athens
uh surrounded by a circle of his friends
in relative obscurity
and allegedly he said it's better not to
marry or have children or get involved
in public life
like you know basically live like a monk
or live like a happy commune or whatever
by all peace and love and try and keep
it tranquil
like whereas the stoics wanted to get
right in the middle of the fray
like they were where you were right in
the agora like you know just
like you know the the stop uncle they
faced the agora
same as socrates would go into
philosophy in the street and at his
friends houses
and so the so the downside of that is
that people would be really
abusive to them people um used to beat
socrates up in the street
like they'd threaten him they'd shout
abuse at him
because he was asking too many questions
and rocking the boat
but socrates was famous for apatheta
like which is you know a term that we
use in stoic philosophy we're told that
it was really socrates that made this
concept famous
he was unrough he was as cool as a
cucumber
and as unruffled as a tortoise
like that's pretty unruffled but he
wouldn't let anything but have you ever
seen a tortoise that looked ruffled
exactly right so that's uh socrates
he wasn't easily phased but the thing
when we talk about temperance and
self-control and ancient philosophy like
one of the most obvious ways that's
manifested
is in being able to have conversations
without losing your temper
and socrates was famous for that epic
titus the stoic teacher
loves socrates goes on and on and on
about him he tells his students that
they should emulate
socrates but then he says something
really weird that i think should freak
out
modern readers of plato he says
you know the most important thing that
you could learn from socrates
is that he never gotten quarrels it
wasn't even the things he said
it was the way that he said them it was
the fact that he was
always good humoured and artfully polite
and even when people got angry with him
like he was able to defuse
it but he never ever lost his temper
with other people
like so talking to people about really
sensitive subjects like religion and
politics and stuff like that
you know often it just degenerates you
see it all the time on the internet
but socrates didn't avoid these
discussions and he also didn't let them
spiral out of control
so he his adversity was facing
argumentative
people bad tempered people now in the
end he did get executed
partly for that and for other things
that he did along the way right
but throughout his life he was known for
this magical ability
this paranormal ability to be able to
talk to people about really sensitive
subjects and
interrogate them about it and for them
for the most part
not to punch them in the face what if
the adversity
isn't so easily cerebrally sort of
explained away it's not just the sort of
thing that you can have a discourse
about
for example a pandemic oh the pandemic
i mean finally enough socrates lived
through a uh a plague
and marx aurelius you you know lived
through the the antonine plague
um i mean you know like books and
stoicism have
shot through the roof in terms of sales
since the beginning of the pandemic
so i think instinctively a lot of people
have felt that stoicism could help them
deal with the adversity of the pandemic
not just because of the historical
connection but they kind of have this
visceral feeling that stoicism is
relevant to dealing with this situation
the ancient stories write a lot about
how to cope with being sent into exile
and i used to think that doesn't seem
that relevant to me in my life
then the pandemic happened we had
quarantining and all that and i thought
all that stuff i read in seneca but
exile suddenly seems really relevant now
it's basically the same thing like i
mean i wasn't sent into exile by the
emperor nero or whatever but i
might as well have been you know i'm not
allowed to leave my house except to go
for groceries
and uh i think it suddenly seems
relevant to people
but i don't i feel like i almost don't
need to persuade people that because it
seems like everyone's figured that out
for themselves they're all reading the
stoics
since the beginning of the pandemic i
think a big there are many aspects that
are relevant and one of them is
um i think i mean maybe i'm wrong about
this but
well there's a couple of things first of
all a lot of people have had to simplify
their lifestyle
during lockdown and so on i feel like
when
you know there are several ways in which
we're not going back to normal
after this uh you never go back like
so after this pandemic ends i wonder how
many people are going to think
us maybe i don't need to go back to
eating out inexpensive restaurants all
the time
by you know me the amount of money that
people blew
on entertainment in the city where i
lived in toronto that's
you know it's full of expensive bars and
restaurants you want
you may not know this but my industry of
14 years i've been a club promoter one
of the biggest in the uk
um and this is something that i am i'm
concerned about for our industry
people used to go out to the same venue
on the same night of the week and then a
different venue on a different night of
the week every single week and that's
where we made our money
it's not so good for you like maybe it's
but it's can also break in that it's a
habit
right for a lot of people right it's
just what they do is they get right
get a bit agitated if it gets to friday
night or whatever
like they're stuck at home we start
pacing up and down like
but uh once the habits broken like after
a few months
they might think but i don't need to go
out as often
i mean it might not take some people
that long to get back into it but i
think some people
why will re-evaluate
their expenditure and re-evaluate the
lifestyle i mean i've spoken you must
have met a lot of people
who everyone's changed their daily
routine so a lot of people are suddenly
doing yoga and going for walks in the
park and all that
i think a lot of people might think
maybe i'll carry on doing yoga and going
for walks in the park even after
the pandemics finished you know because
maybe they they've realized that it's
healthier than what they were doing
before and
maybe they're actually a lot of people
are happier not everyone some people are
really struggling psychologically
but a lot of people actually feel that
they're better off like it's you know
it's improved their mental health having
to deal with the lockdown
and again one of the paradoxical aspects
of that is coming to terms with your own
mortality
you know the thing that again isn't
really talked about that much in
self-help
art life lifehack articles and and
whatnot
um i wrote an article about this
recently where i thought i'm going to do
the opposite and just really get into
the gut so this whole everyone's going
to die thing
like because i i really believe it's
it's liberating when i was a young guy
it was quite reckless
and you know a couple of times i got
into situations where i thought
oh geez maybe my time's up this is it
buddy
um you know just because i did stupid
things when i was a teenager
and then you know maybe people have
health scales and stuff i give a talk
once when asked
how many people in the audience put your
hand up have you ever had a brush with
death
either through health scare or a
dangerous situation i think it was about
two-thirds of the audience
why can i surprise me and i said was it
what you thought it was going to be
like like were you scared and a lot of
people they had a bit of a chat about it
and
what emerged was a lot of people said
well in an emergency often you don't
really have time to feel scared
you're more just kind of like focused on
getting out of there or dealing with a
situation or whatever
and sometimes you feel incredibly calm
when you you think
like maybe this is a it's not what
people imagine it to be necessarily
and i think it's different for everyone
but um
for me also being bereaved and losing
someone close to you can have a similar
effect i think
of making you reappraise your values
and think look back on you because it
makes you look at your life
if you have time right and
and think oh geez you know like was it
worth it
like you know if if i if i dodge this
bullet and i get another chance
should i go right back on facebook or
watch another season of friends or
whatever
like and so it makes you really think
those things i was doing were they just
like ways of killing time
or were they actually kind of meaningful
and fulfilling things
one of the things we learned from modern
psychotherapy evidence-based
psychotherapy
cutting edge of evidence-based
psychotherapy for clinical depression
we used to think uh people with clinical
depression weren't doing enough
enjoyable things so but aaron beck the
founder of cognitive therapy his big
innovation was
part of it was to do activity scheduling
and get people to do more pleasurable
activities during the day
actually like he didn't invent that
technique it was a guy called peter
lewinson that doesn't get credit for it
that invented that technique but beck
was wrong anyway
so we we now know that that's slightly
off
it's not pleasurable activities that
that help people with depression it's
meaningful activities
like there's a subtle difference between
something that makes you feel happy
like it gives you kind of warm glow and
something that actually
makes you feel fulfilled in a deeper
sense
right so maybe eating in chocolate you
know
or having sex or watching a comedy kind
of makes you feel good
but like it's not necessarily going to
make you
a more fulfilled person in the long term
like
if the rest of your life is kind of
pointless why and you don't feel that
you've got any direction
and so what really seems to emerge
pretty quickly just once you start
asking people the right questions
is the again where we started buddy is
people don't know what their values are
and so if you don't know what your real
values are in life then how do you know
what it is that you should be doing all
day long every day
and you know a sudden brush with a grim
reaper might be what it takes
like for people to suddenly think maybe
i need to figure out
what i actually value in life what
you know no one has ever had on a
tombstone engraved
i wish i'd spent more time on facebook
or i wish i'd watched more netflix right
so i think the pandemic has forced a lot
of people to
have that existential crisis and
reappraise our values and
you know we need to i think we should
need to push people further in that
direction
you know to question those values and
then start actually putting them into
practice
more and then maybe we wouldn't have as
many riots and stuff
one of my favorite passages in fact
probably my favorite passage
from the entire book i'm just going to
read it out here
looking back it seems more obvious to me
now than ever before that the lives of
most men are tragedies of their own
making
men let themselves either get puffed up
with pride or tormented by grievances
everything they concern themselves with
is fragile trivial and fleeting
we're left with nowhere to stand firm
amidst the torrent
of things rushing past there's nothing
secure in which we can invest our hopes
what's that mean
exactly what we've been talking about
like when you do
um behavioral analysis with clinically
depressed clients
what emerges from it is a lot of the
things the more depressed someone is the
more
time they're going to spend doing
avoidant behaviors
so if you say what did you do all day
yesterday
often it's mainly things that just help
them to avoid
feelings of boredom feelings of anxiety
like
i drank i took drugs scrolled down my
phone
masturbated like slept you know
like why did you you know like did those
things kind of like really make you feel
like a more fulfilled individual or
you know i just felt like i needed to do
something i was starting to feel bored
so i agitated so i mean a life that's
driven by avoidance
and doing things in order to avoid
feelings
is never going to really be a healthy or
satisfying
life they're they're sort of away from
goals we're doing this in order to get
away
from unpleasant feelings whereas what
you really want are towards goals i'm
doing it because i really love this
thing
you know i love learning i love wisdom i
love creativity
you know i want to do more of that stuff
i'll tell you one of the scary things
like whenever we do values clarification
with people which is
something that therapist has been doing
since the 70s and it's it's quite
one of the parts of therapy that's most
influenced by socrates
so we get someone to identify their
values let's say
uh with a bit of work a bit of effort
and then we might say well
okay let's say yesterday roughly how
much time did you spend
doing stuff that's consistent with your
values and the most common answer
you're saying how many minutes are i was
the most common answer i hear from
people is
zero right and that at first that really
shocked me
i thought they're going to say maybe
half the time or a few hours no it's
usually
zero zero like i spent
zero minutes all week doing anything
that i thought was of any intrinsic
value
why over and over again it's crazy isn't
it
embarrassingly well not embarrassingly
but i
it took me 31 years until the beginning
of last year for me to ever work out my
core values
and upon reading that quote uh about how
amidst the torrent of things rushing
past there's nothing secure in which we
can invest our hopes
that passage to me is talking about
someone who is
living an unintentional life they
haven't consciously reflected on what it
is that they want
to want in life and they're just blown
along by
societal norms and genetic
predisposition and paths of least
resistance and the way they dealt with
past traumas
all that stuff and it is only upon the
time that we sit back we give ourselves
that mindfulness gap
and we think okay what do i want to want
what are the things that i hold so dear
that i'm prepared to sacrifice the
things that are easy in order to get
them
the cynic and stoic philosophers have a
name for it they call it t-force
or two-force depending on how you want
to pronounce it it means
like smoke or mist um like uh
maya like the veil of illusion except
they think it comes from people's
opinions
so it's like the prevailing values of
society
they say it's all smoking mirrors why so
we live in this world where we come that
we're thrown into the world as babies
by we grow up we look around we copy the
adults around us we don't know what
we're supposed to be doing
but like a blank slate in a sense and we
see everyone else running around like
crazy
uh trying to maintain their reputation
and accumulate wealth and property
so we're growing up inevitably we think
i guess that's what you're supposed to
do
like i guess what many try and get a
better car than other people
and like you know get the best job and
it's really awful if you if you if you
don't
get a promotion and pass all your exams
and stuff like that
and so we get indoctrinated generation
after generation after generation since
the dawn of history
into pursuing external extrinsic goals
because maybe because the very very ways
our society and our brains are built
and the way our language works and then
maybe we get a shock
a brush with death or a bereavement or
something makes us think more deeply
um and we start to think is this really
making me happy
maybe maybe it's all bs like
maybe it doesn't really make you happy
like and the pandemic maybe for some
people it's got like maybe my job wasn't
making me happy
do you know as a therapist one of the
main adversities that i deal with
two of the main ones are relationship
breakups and redundancy
right and you know of course
it seems like a trauma to many people
that their marriage ends or their
relationship ends
or they get sacked or made redundant or
whatever but very often
like six months later might turn out to
be for the best
like maybe they've gone on to bear
relationship or
about there are many people that leave
their jobs
like in middle age let's say and then go
on to do something that they actually
want to do
like it's the you know maybe the worst
thing that can happen to somebody in
life
is that they never lose their job like
you know because then maybe they're
stuck
doing whatever it was that they just
started to stumble into doing
in life i think there are many people
that are just doing a job that they you
know
they ended up doing because it was
convenient and but maybe it's not
fulfilling to them
one of the things i've been thinking
about a lot recently is the term
it was meant to be when used
retrospectively
so a lot of the time a situation will
occur perhaps an adversity or perhaps
even a good thing or whatever it might
be
and then out the back of that however
many weeks or months later
someone says well it was meant to be
because look at where i am now
and to me with my particular
metaphysical view of the world
that seems to rob all of the beauty and
agency from how that person's dealt with
the situation
how about the causation runs in the
opposite direction
that a thing happened and you made it
work
that you lost your job had a bereavement
broke up with your partner
and the outcome of that you were so
capable you had so much upward mobility
that you
made you wrangled the world into the
outcome that you wanted
it wasn't meant to be you made it be
yeah the i mean the stoics
you mentioned facing adversity earlier
which is really what this is all about
yeah the stoics think by nature we kind
of avoid adversity
um but they think the paradox is we
should undertake voluntary hardship like
we should go out of our comfort zone and
seek out challenges
because we're probably better at coping
in a sense than than we assume
we're survivors generally speaking the
so i think we have to be careful this is
something that people
miss about stoicism when we face
adversity we've got to judge
whether we're going to be overwhelmed by
it or whether it and the analogy would
be choosing like a sparring partner
an ancient wrestling or a martial art so
you don't pick someone who's really easy
and not a challenge
but you don't pick some guy that's twice
the size of you who's just going to
flatten you into a pulp right
so obviously you can engage it and you
pick something that's going to be
challenging but not overwhelming and so
that's what the stoics have to say about
adversity epictetus
pretty much says exactly that to his
students um
he says you'll only know from your own
experience what
you can actually handle like but you
should always be kind of pushing
yourself to take on challenges
so that you can you know trust in your
coping ability and strengthen your
coping ability but obviously don't
bite off more than you can chew um i you
know i think people are too timid in a
sense
um epictetus also said to students they
love
hercules and hercules is the favorite
demigod or a god
of the stoics in greek mythology and
they love the
the myth of the the twelve labels of
hercules and epictetus says to his
students
but you guys are always telling me how
you're kind of like trying to avoid
problems in life and stuff he said let
me ask you a question
if hercules had laying in bed under the
covers
and been attended on by other men and
he'd never
wandered the earth in poverty persecuted
by other people
facing one monster after another like do
you honestly
think that you would still admire him he
wouldn't even be worthy of the name
hercules
he says the only reason you admire him
is because he got
hammered like with adversity
like and he stood up to it through
self-discipline
and courage like he persevered but he
had one of the idea of the twelve labels
is that hercules had
like the toughest life ever like he was
constantly kind of battling and
struggling
he was being persecuted by the goddess
hero like so he made
enemies in in high places as it were and
so that's what he kind of represents
um sepita said surely but you guys think
the opposite
you you know you just want to avoid
trouble like and have an easy life but
then you'll die
like you'll be on your deathbed and you
look back at it and you'll think jesus
spent a lot of time in bed
just kind of like watching tv and stuff
like you know trust me when you know
when your time's up and you look back
you know it's all the kind of challenges
that you faced and that you overcame
the things that you're most likely to
have some kind of sense of satisfaction
from
you know it's the times when you pushed
yourself and went out of your comfort
zone
like that makes your life meaningful um
you know you won't even remember i
challenge you to remember
what happens in most of the episodes of
friends or whatever you know
like uh the amount of tv that people
watch in our society
you think about how much of it can they
actually remember like so then what was
the point of it
it was just a way of killing time as
marcus aurelius says quote
heraclitus you know we were like men
asleep
like in a dream or something like that
you know walking about in a trance
and the stories want us to snap out of
that you know to wake up like
contemplation of death is when we're
doing that but really it's kind of
existential crisis that
they want to evoke in us like to to you
know really rethink
everything dramatically to turn our life
upside down the cynics used to symbolize
that
by walking backwards um it always
reminds me you know that video with the
verve
with richard ashcroft whatever his name
is putting the jacket on
and bumping into all these people and
all that that's this is he's a cynic
philosopher buddy
like that's exactly what they did right
and uh they'd wait until everybody was
coming out the theater
and then walk into the crowd and bump
into them all and people would say to
diogenes why are you doing that you're
going the wrong way
and he'd say i'm just practicing for
something
that i do my whole life long well i am
training myself
it goes because i'm swimming against the
current fund me
existentially throughout my whole life
you know i'm going against the
prevailing
values of athenian society you know and
you've got to toughen yourself up to do
that
people are going to laugh at me why tell
me i'm
i'm doing everything back to front like
but when you're surrounded by smoking
mirrors
right in all the bs of society and
hedonism narcissism celebrity culture
consumerism
santa claus you know all that coca-cola
like you know all that kind of stuff
like
people are going to think you're crazy
if you reject it why
try and rise above it and the cynics
were like you're going to have to
practice what they called
shamelessness or we calling we do a
similar thing in therapy today we call
it shame attacking
to toughen up like so you don't really
care if everybody laughs at you
um because you're gonna have to be
laughed at if you're gonna
you know strike out on your own and you
know have the courage to do things
differently
is that an inevitability now even in the
modern world because i think
it's easy to hear about these ancient
times
and think yeah yeah but that were you
know they were they were totally
uncivilized and
they were these sort of ridiculous
individuals and maybe there's a little
bit of drama and
artistic license being used and we
presume
that because it's so such a civilized
civilization now
that we shouldn't be being ostracized
for the things that we say we shouldn't
be being
out on a limb we shouldn't be going into
exile and walking backwards outside of
the theater
it sounds like it sounds ridiculous now
is that still the case for someone who
wants the consciously designed life
is that an inevitable price to pay yeah
i thought i'm hoping when i go back to
toronto next actually that i see people
doing that
like there's a lot of people that are
interested in so i want to see that on
the streets of toronto anyone that's
listening
like out there in canada like or
anywhere really all the major cities i'd
like to see people doing that now if
they're into stoicism
no i like in modern society it's just
the same you know
family are going to think you're a
weirdo like you know your girlfriend's
going to think you've gone crazy
you know people at work are going to
think you're nuts like if you
you know like like i said earlier like
when i was a kid
i don't know i was kind of lucky in some
ways the um the first job i had
when i i was uh kicked out of school
when i was a kid
um because there was a bit of a tear
away and i got in a lot of trouble with
local cops and stuff
so i had that kind of bad start and it
was like the best thing that ever
happened to me
um because it made me kind of you know
rethink things
and uh you know what i was going to say
the uh it made me it made me
realize you know that i had to kind of
find a sense a direction
and purpose in life and i was lucky
because i found uh
stumbled into a pretty well paid job in
the tech industry
um and i walked out on it to go into a
degree in philosophy
and pete i remember the time people
saying are you crazy
well if you do a philosophy degree like
how are you going to get a job at the
end of it you've got really sweet
you've landed on your feet your buddy
they said
why and are you nuts like people would
give that right arm
like to be where you i was only 19 or
something like that
uh and i thought i remember i think at
the time though i fight i think this is
meaningless i don't want to just like
sit in this office even if i'm getting
paid well for
it i thought do i do this for the rest
of my life
why sit in an office and can i shuffle
paper and draw diagrams and stuff
right so i walked out on it but i
remember as a young guy that feeling of
everybody around me like
looking at me like i'd lost my mind and
thinking that you know
i was abandoning something that they
thought was really valuable
but they were all wrong like it was all
the bs and smoking mirrors of society
it was a great job it was like a prison
sentence like plato's cave or something
like that
you know i got paid a kind of
comfortable amount of money
for doing something that to me was like
we would be like sitting in a prison
cell all day
you know well i'm gonna do that for the
rest of my life you know i'd rather be
broke
by and have the freedom to sit around
and talk
in nonsense to strangers about uh
ancient greeks
like we're doing now what you and i are
doing here you know i wouldn't be here
today if it wasn't for that you wouldn't
be able to enjoy
the pleasure of my company how can
people overcome that inertia
societal norms societal norms are strong
you know the desire to be wanted and
liked and accepted
is is important and someone thinks hey
that sounds like me donald you're
talking to me i don't feel fulfilled in
my life i don't know my values my
meaning
but i'm also [ __ ] scared of leaving this
cushy job and what will my friends say
how do they get over the inertia
i think you have to practice in a number
of ways i mean the stories give us a
whole barrage of techniques to toughen
ourselves up
i like i'm going to go straight for the
jugular and say that i think
contemplating mortality is a
you know like the nuclear option in
store so it's the most powerful
technique
now i don't think that psychologically
is for everybody like someone suffers
from
clinical depression and they're suicidal
then i'm going to say contemplate your
own math probably not right
but if someone's fairly resilient and
they think they can cope with it
seneca used to say to himself every
night when he went to bed
i'm not going to wake up in the morning
why and he'd try and imagine that that
was it his time was up why he was going
to go to sleep and
and not wake up the next morning and i i
would ask himself am i am i good with
that
like can i look back on my life and and
think yeah you know
i can't you know i can rest easy with
this i'm satisfied with how it's been so
far
or if not like what am i gonna do
differently marcus really says imagine
that you're already dead
but you've got an extension you're on
like you've got you're in a penalty time
or whatever
like you've got you've got some extra
time right
like he goes further than saying imagine
that you've only got a day left or
whatever he's like imagine you're
already toast
like but they've decided to be generous
and give you an extension
so that i think is a powerful technique
it is do you think that the stoics had
much of a sense of humor because it's
easy to hear
this is very serious talk i'm going to
bed contemplating death i'm waking up
contemplating death everything's about
death and being serious and avoiding
emotion
you know they had a sense that like i
think there's a couple of ways of
refuting this idea right number one is
socrates is the godfather of stoicism
like you know epictetus saying you know
we love socrates you stimulate them
no one in the right mind would say that
socrates was like mr spock or star trek
they're not two people that you would
ever confuse if you met mr spock in your
nightclub or whatever would you look at
him and think
is that socrates i think what's up with
his ears yeah exactly like
they're not they're not two people that
you would have because socrates is has
got it was very humorous
um he's very charming he's witty
like and that that makes him come across
as a more rounded and
emotional person and the stoics wrote
books like the stoic wrote satires we
have a bunch of stoic satires from
uh perseus the uh it was a friend of
seneca
and uh seneca has uh we've got a stupid
satire that seneca wrote
called the pumpkinification of claudius
that still survives today
and uh chris ipis uh the
third head of the store wrote about
jokes and he actually died
laughing at one of his own jokes about a
donkey
a heart attack or something yeah like
it's like have you seen that monty
python sketch about the joke in the
first world war
like that's so funny that everybody that
hears it dies
have you never seen that everybody
everyone else will have done i'm getting
abused in the comments for that one
the government the british government in
the first world well they say well it's
so dangerous we had to translate it into
german
but we would only give each person one
word
so that nobody knew the whole joke like
because if they heard that they would
die laughing at it and then they start
they train these guys like they're you
know like
they're like they're putting them ear
plugs in and they're shouting
out like along the train shoes of the
germans it's a day like it's a deadly
weapon
like the funniest joke in the world you
can see how
people might think that though right
with about the stoics it sounds like a
serious sort of thing how do you marry
this incredibly
uh sort of existential view of life
with being jovial and and free who's
more hardcore than the stoics but
their predecessors the cynics and the
cynics were
known for
of the funniest satisfying we to a large
extent we only know he we don't have any
books by him
we only know about him from anecdotes
and a lot of those anecdotes come from
comedies come from south isles
there's a weird relationship marcus
release loved
um old comedy like uh
you know the the early style a greek
comedy there's there's like a weird um
relationship between greek comedy in
particular and philosophy
and like greek comedy had these stock
characters where there would be like a
really pretentious guy
and then like a yoko that would kind of
act dumb
uh like feign ignorance but but somehow
always kind of get the upper hand
over the pretentious aristocrat this is
they thought this was hilarious
right um so they had a lot of comedies
that revolved around this and a lot of
people have said
that's weirdly like socrates though
like because he says i know nothing and
he just asks lots of questions
you know he does it in this good humored
way but he always seems to get the upper
hand over these aristocrats and experts
that
you know and he said his socratic method
was a
therapy therapeut for um
a talking cure it uses words rather than
pharmaceuticals or drugs or hair herbs
but he said it's uh he says this very
clearly several times
in the apology people often don't notice
it uh
what was it a cure for he says it was a
cure for arrogance
or conceit which the greeks they'd be
like that's like the comedies that's the
whole point of
of the old comedies it's punctured
busting the bubble of of people's
arguments you can see
so it's a really weird thing that
everybody must have looked at socrates
and thought he resembles this buffoon
and in comedies and yet like
the delphic oracle like the pagan pope
in a sense
like it says that no man is wiser than
this
you know it's a weird deeply socrates
fascinates me i mean i think he's like
this like vortex of one paradox or
enigma
within another he's such a multi-layered
uh
character um but yeah
that's a big part of it so comedy i
think is a big part of i think you can
only really laugh at yourself
and laugh at life if you kind of gain
this freedom that comes from
questioning um you know the the the
some of the values that prevail in our
our society i think of it's actually a
liberating
thing and and quite the opposite of uh
you know this stultifying gravity that
you know really i think is a more of a
sign of
everything the stoics we're trying to to
uproot and challenge
is there a quote that you come back to
the most from stoicism was there a
shot through the heart when you read it
something that particularly
had a heavy impact on you or anything
that comes to mind
it's hard actually because i studied the
stoics so closely and for so many years
like 25 years or something now
and um so i'm like i like all of it
really
but my actually my favorite quotes are
things like
um seneca says to learn how to die is to
unlearn how to be a slave
and i think that's that's like that's
pretty heavy
like there are many things that are
reading the story wow that's heavy
um so that's one of my one of my
favorite ones
and everyone likes that quote from
marcus really is where he says stop
arguing about what it means to be a good
man and just be one
why i picked up for the first time for
the first time ever i picked up in the
happiness hypothesis by jonathan height
the whole universe has changed and life
itself is but what you deem it
and it's those last eight words life
itself is but what you deem it
like is a such a mic drop he
like that quote and and marcus aurelius
is and by the way like i think the other
thing i want to see when i get back to
toronto
like my kind of my current home sort of
is what you see all these hipsters that
are into stores all the millennials that
work in the tech industry
walking backwards and i want them all to
have that tattoo
like that says life has changed
like the whole universe life is the way
it's often translated right
what marcus aurelius does there is his
two favorite philosophers are heraclitus
and epictetus so heraclitus is this
pre-socratic philosopher
that said uh pantare everything flows
like a river you can't step into the
same river twice
because it's new water that's constantly
flowing through and he said the whole
universe
is imp impermanent everything is in flux
which reminds me of a joke
like this is one of my few philosophy
jokes how many heraclitums does it take
to change a light bulb
i don't know only one but he can't
change the same light bulb twice
right i'm not even sure that makes
sense i don't think it does no
it's not kind of funny you can't step
into the same river twice is what yeah
right and so marx really loves him and
he quotes him a lot although
his philosophy was always associated
with stoicism um and then his other
favorite philosopher his his main
favorite philosopher actually is
epictetus and so that quote
it's six words in greek right so it's
really concise
um and he's he's referring to heraclitus
the universe is change
that's heraclitus's philosophy and the
other bit that says life is opinion
is referring to epictetus what i'm sorry
donal what's the alternative translation
that you're using there because i've
said life itself is but what you deem it
and what's what's your one life is
opinion
life is opinion is how it's often the
word he uses
is uh um
hypo hypolipsis
um which kind of means actually means
like a value judgment
um so he said what he's really say
because he explains it actually in the
preceding paragraph right he's saying
this is his way of summing up the whole
philosophy of epictetus
so it's a shorthand way of saying
it's not things that upset us but our
opinions are valued it's the same word
like uh beliefs it's our value judgments
that upset us
so what he means is um not that
everything is opinion
but the quality of our life is shaped
by our value judgments like so what we
deem things to be
is fundamental to our quality of life
because it shapes whether we're angry or
sad or what our value judgments are
it doesn't just mean that everything is
subjective like the stoics
weren't skeptics like that like but he
thinks that our opinions and value
judgments like we say in cognitive
therapy
you know are the way we think about life
is what shapes our emotional uh
experience
it's fascinating man like so it's a good
tattoo like
i'll tell you my other let's talk about
stoic tattoos that's one of my favorite
things to talk about on podcasts
is that is that common yeah like there's
a whole
um like someone showed me a webpage
there's all pinterest boards
or is it like a bust of marcus they're
mainly marcus aurelius's face
like and then they're like some of them
have a little quote or a symbol or
whatever
um so there's one um i like that says
nothing terrible has happened to you and
there's one i want to get the tattoo i
want to get is from epic titus
where he says to his students um
what does he say uh i think it's
something like uh
do it says uh it's me
me uh uh
oipoi i think in greek um my greeks
about rusty
but me it's it's very short it just
means uh do not say
it's hard to translate it's usually
translated as alas
so like um i would translate it as
saying
do not say what the [ __ ] like
or do not do not say do not say oh no
like don't freak out why is kind of what
he's saying
do not say alas is the victorian english
what's that mean to you um don't impose
strong catastrophic value judgments on
external events
that's such a more like well elucidate
this version
yeah exactly
donald man um i feel like i've not even
got through half of the stuff that i
wanted to do so i'm gonna have to get
you back on
um but this has been done so haven't
told you
my secret project tell us about your
secret project that's what i want to
know about
i've got two i'm only going to tell you
about one of them i'm not going to tell
you but
please a secret within a secret well i
keep telling people about this like
because i said this on a podcast
so i was talking to some guy in a
podcast and just off the top of my head
was talking about being half in athens
and i said you know the thing that i
find about sad in athens is plato's
academy
park is not far from here and um the
ruins
we believe of plato's academy school are
there
but you know like the local greeks go
there but there's nothing much there
and i said what i really think we should
do is rebuild plato's academy
by and make it like an international
center for our practical philosophy
so i said that in a podcast a while back
and people started
phone started ringing like people
started getting in touch with me so my
secret project now
is we've got uh we've got a plan
for doing something um
vis-a-vis plato's academy park
um to maybe kind of get like get people
coming there to
to learn about philosophy and the you
know in the location of the original
uh academy like the first ever like
educational institution in the history
of western civilization
it's where it all started and now it's
come full circle
well i mean i when i was in athens i was
so disappointed with this because i i
love tours i'm a massive fan of a tour
i'll get a get
a fella on a wireless mic and i'll stick
a pair of headphones in and just listen
to him and walk and talk for three hours
one of the things i saw on trip advisor
as i obsess over it before i go
somewhere
was a explanation
of socrates philosophy
explained through a live socratic
dialogue
done on an evening time over dinner so
you'd go for dinner in this
courtyard and there would be an
explanation but it was done in the style
of a socratic dialogue
in athen and i was like this is awesome
[ __ ] sick and the it was out of
season
and they were like oh we only do it we
only do it in the summer months and i
thought he bastards
surprised me why but there's not many
things like that but occasionally they
crop up that would be awesome
though but they i'm always a bit
disappointed like i take people
i kind of i i'm one of these people that
insists on on
telling everybody what everything is you
know but if people are interested in
philosophy i'd make a great tour guide
why because i love taking people and
showing them around and i'm like no one
ever tells you
like this is where socrates was actually
executed or the theater dionysus
i call it the place the athenians used
to go to laugh at socrates
right so the theater inside the
acropolis no one ever tells you that
like you know the big one the bit the
big one without yeah that's you're
thinking of the audience
atticus okay so they uh they have
concerts still
like sting or whoever will play that's
like a big
theater um now there's a smaller one a
little bit just a little bit along from
it
um this like it was used in the ancient
uh festival a dionysus i think i know
the one that you mean wasn't it the one
that was closest to what they used as a
hospital
and they sometimes wheeled the patients
out because they they saw that theater
was part of that
it's just a little bit further down the
path right lower down and a bit more
toward the main entrance
that's true uh yeah like it's a lot bit
further away
um yeah yeah it's towards one of the one
of the entrances people laughed at
socrates then
yeah like the aristophanes performed the
clouds there which is
like a parody of socrates there's a
story that socrates went
to and he sat in the audience and there
was these two guys
from maguera like another city tourists
and they were like because it absolutely
mercilessly
like you know humiliates and ridicules
them makes them out to be a pretentious
idiot
and one of these guys turned to the
other guy and he went
who's this dude that they're just
roasting here like and socrates was
sitting beside him
and he the story goes that he stood up
and he turned around to the audience and
he went
to me and then he kind of just sat down
and he smiled and he said
so like the the symbolism of it is that
he didn't he was uh
he had apathy yeah i was like i don't
care like what if the ducks back to me
i'm quite enjoying ash
man so good look donald uh i really
really
adored today uh if people want to check
out more of your work
and your accessible writings where
should they go well like if they just
got my website it's just donald
robertson.name so instead of calm it's
n-a-m-e
like donald robinson.name and like i've
have a lot of videos and
books and i'm working on a graphic novel
at the moment so they'll see some of the
artwork for that
and uh yeah like they'll be hearing
shortly about
some of the secret pro not so secret
projects that um
i'm working on i guess if they if
they're interested in and that
so yeah that's where they can fit and
also the modern stores as a
non-profit it's like a philanthropic
organization i'm one of the founding
members of it
it's run by a multidisciplinary team of
philosophers and
classicists and psychologists the
website for that is just modern
stoicism.com
and it runs conferences and online
courses
like uh you know basically like like i
say non-profit
so that that's where i generally steer
people towards actually
like they can support the the work of
the organization and just
educating people about the benefits of
stoicism how to be a roman emperor
is the most accessible work do you think
a good place to start
i've written um yeah i mean it's the one
that people seem to like
um and you know i wrote a teach yourself
self-help book
called stoicism in the art of of
happiness like i've written a bunch of
books but
like the one that people seem to like is
how to when i first i suggested that
title
10 years ago and the first publisher
told me they thought it was a stupid
idea for a title
and uh and i thought i never i never
gave up
like i thought i thought i like it is a
stupid title
i think it's a stupid title but that's
why i like it
and eventually i managed to find a
publisher that would let me use it
and now suddenly they think it's a great
idea they're like that's a great title
like in retrospect in retrospect but at
first everybody thought it was kind of
it was funny um so yeah by all means
the romanian translation just came out i
saw congratulations all the people in
romania getting red pilled about
stoicism
quite excited about that the greek
translation is doing okay i like that i
like it when i see the greeks reading it
why you know because they're not really
that into stoicism so like i quite like
to see that crazy
look mate thank you so much for today
it's been amazing
oh it's been a pleasure thank you very
much and you know like uh
yeah maybe hopefully some point in the
future like we can chat again
i'm sure there'll be plenty to talk
about
[Music]